même couleur qu'en 2015 une seule
n'apparaît pas celle de l'abstention
65,7 % des électeurs ont boudé les urnes
ce dimanche
un chiffre qui ternit la victoire de
l'ancien monde pour ces régionales 2021
comme lors du premier tour c'est le
grand test qui est le plus touché avec
70% d'abstention
les présidents de région sortants de
droite et socialistes largement réélu
voient ainsi leur légitimité amoindri
par la participation très faible pour
certains l'intérêt pour ces régionales a
été entravée par le manque
d'informations je n'ai rien reçu dans ma
boîte aux lettres et c'est vrai qu'au
niveau des élections j'ai pas eu
beaucoup d'informations donc on fait que
j'ai pas réellement envie de me déplacer
pour aller voter
certains espéraient une plus grande
mobilisation des électeurs pour ce
second tour
un sursaut qui ne s'est pas manifesté
malgré un rebond minime d'un peu plus
d'un point de participation cela reste
infiniment moins qu'aux dernières
régionales en 2015 avec un écart entre
les deux scrutins de plus de 20 points
mais les régionales ne sont pas un vote
qui mobilise certains se sentent peu
concernés par cette élection dont les
enjeux sont mal connus
on sait pas vraiment intéressé au sujet
et on a du mal à savoir vraiment pour
qui on vote pour quoi c'est un peu
compliqué j'ai pas le temps franchement
demeure intéressé il me semble que c'est
des petites sélections qui ont dors je
n'arrive pas à cerner l'importance en
fait par rapport à la présidentielle
mais cette abstention record c'est aussi
le signe d'un grand manque de confiance
dans l'appareil politique
on a vraiment l'impression que
quel que soit le vote de toute façon
sera pas représentée comme on le
souhaite donc là pour le coup on s'est
abstenu j'ai pour confiance
sont de plus en plus vite de plus en
plus dans la précarité
personne ne nous vient
il ya des germes ans à la télévision
d'abord c'est ça
ça c'est parce
c'est pas
suivis d'actes là je préfère être dans
les deux tiers des gens qui se sont
abstenus je pense que là c'est plus
marquants l'abstention comme troisième
voie un silence des électeurs en guise
de vote sanction pour ce scrutin et
particulièrement pour les candidats lrm
le parti la république en marche qui ne
s'est pas emparé d'une seule région à
voir si cette voie de l'abstention
résonnera dans les couloirs de l'elysée